hola, mi nombre es Olivia Lan y soy investigadora y educadora en IBM Quantum, este video marca el lanzamiento de una
nueva serie en el canal de YouTube de Qiskit y en nuestra plataforma de aprendizaje llamada Quantum Computing in
practice, en resumen, en esta serie te voy a mostrar cómo usar una computadora cuántica que existe ahora mismo al máximo de su
potencial, ya hay miles de millones de videos en internet sobre computadoras cuánticas y su potencial futuro, o sobre conceptos teóricos
detrás de la computación cuántica, que también son igual de importantes, ve "Understanding Quantum Information and Computation"
presentado por John Watrous, por ejemplo, pero en este curso vamos a asumir que el estudiante quizás ya sabe un poco más
de lo que hemos asumido antes y vamos a ir muy lejos en lo técnico, y eso se debe a que durante el año pasado y en el
momento de esta grabación es 2024, hemos visto un cambio, una transición de fase, por así decirlo, hacia una nueva era de
computación: las computadoras cuánticas finalmente se están acercando al punto en que pueden ser útiles, aunque experimentar con
circuits a pequeña escala y computadoras cuánticas fue necesario para educar a nuestra comunidad sobre cómo usar estas máquinas, nadie estaba ejecutando experimentos
que tampoco pudieran realizarse en computadoras clásicas convencionales, pero a partir de hoy hemos entrado en una era de
utilidad cuántica, y ¿qué es la utilidad?, te preguntarás, es diferente a la Ventaja Cuántica, que puede entenderse como el
punto en el que las computadoras cuánticas superan a las clásicas en una tarea significativa, en cambio, la utilidad significa
que pueden empezar a competir entre sí, y este es el siguiente paso natural en la evolución
tecnológica: IBM publicó un artículo que mostró por primera vez el año pasado que una computadora cuántica podía usarse para
simular un modelo físico y competir con las técnicas de simulación clásica más avanzadas, incluso superó los
intentos de fuerza bruta y les dio a los investigadores una nueva vía que pueden usar para la investigación, entonces ¿por qué está pasando todo esto
ahora? pues bien, en los últimos meses IBM ha puesto ampliamente disponibles procesadores cuánticos de más de 100 qubits, si ya eres
usuario, puede que hayas notado que retiramos muchos de nuestros procesadores más pequeños para dar paso a estos chips más grandes, y nos pareció realmente
importante hacerlo porque algunos números de qubits aún pueden simularse clásicamente sin problema, así que no hay
ninguna ventaja real que se pueda obtener usando esos chips, sin embargo a 100 qubits este ya no es el caso, no pueden
simularse clásicamente, también es importante señalar que existen estas cosas llamadas simuladores, que
son esencialmente programas de computadora y pueden imitar algunos comportamientos de los sistemas cuánticos, incluyendo el ruido, sin embargo por favor
no pases por alto que dije imitar: los simuladores no son computadoras cuánticas, no pueden producir los resultados que
las computadoras cuánticas pueden a esta escala, pero siguen siendo una parte importante de nuestro flujo de trabajo de pruebas, así que esa fue una
respuesta muy extensa a la pregunta al inicio de esta diapositiva: ¿qué es la computación cuántica práctica? en este curso voy a enseñarte sobre casos de uso
realistas y potenciales para lo cuántico y las mejores prácticas para ejecutar y experimentar en estos procesadores de mayor escala
hoy en día, ¿a quién está dirigido este curso? comencemos estableciendo algunos niveles de referencia
desde el principio: este curso es para todo aquel que quiera desarrollar nuevas aplicaciones para computadoras cuánticas,
quiera saber cómo escalar su trabajo actual o aprender a usar lo cuántico en sus flujos de trabajo existentes, antes
mencioné que este curso será muy práctico y no hablaremos de aspectos teóricos tanto,
esperamos que llegues con una comprensión básica de qué es la computación cuántica, pero si todavía no estás ahí, no te preocupes, solo mira
los primeros episodios del curso de John Watrous y estarás listo/a, también queremos asegurarnos de que los espectadores sepan
que esto no es solo un curso para físicos o incluso informáticos, estas dos áreas realmente han
acaparado la computación cuántica durante la última década aproximadamente, queremos asegurarnos de que otros que trabajan con big data o
simulaciones, como ingenieros, químicos y científicos de materiales, sepan que este curso también es para ellos, en resumen, este
curso está dirigido a una audiencia amplia y esperamos que te unas a nosotros durante toda su duración, al completar este curso
podrás entender cómo crear y ejecutar un trabajo a escala de utilidad a través del runtime de Qiskit, incluyendo el flujo de trabajo completo,
podrás entender los principales tipos de mitigación de errores y también entender las áreas de aplicación probables a corto plazo, también podrás
implementar todos estos algoritmos en Qiskit y por último esperamos que puedas entender el ruido y cómo manejarlo,
así que empecemos: la computación cuántica es una emocionante tecnología nueva en una etapa temprana de desarrollo, pero es solo
un capítulo en la historia de la computación, que se remonta a miles de años, creo que es importante entender este
contexto porque hace que lo que pretendemos hacer aquí sea un poco más intuitivo, predecible y menos
de ciencia ficción: desde la antigüedad, nosotros como humanos hemos necesitado realizar cálculos o
en otras palabras, procesar información de acuerdo con ciertas reglas y restricciones para poder habilitar
la comunicación, la construcción, el comercio, la ciencia y todos los demás aspectos de nuestras vidas, nos hemos apoyado en el mundo físico
en busca de ayuda y a través de ingeniosos descubrimientos hemos construido dispositivos que nos ayudan a calcular, hace mucho tiempo los dispositivos se
hacían de madera, hueso, cuerdas anudadas y almacenaban información y facilitaban los cálculos de manera muy diferente a como lo hacemos
hoy los dispositivos mecánicos construidos con palancas, engranajes y otras maquinarias evolucionaron desde los primeros relojes astronómicos hasta
calculadoras y sofisticados dispositivos de cómputo, como los analizadores diferenciales que resolvían ecuaciones con ruedas y
discos giratorios; incluso la tecnología de la escritura ha jugado un papel importante en esta historia al permitir que las personas realicen
cómputos que de otro modo no podrían hacer. Cuando pensamos en computadoras hoy en día, tendemos a pensar en
computadoras digitales electrónicas, pero en realidad se trata de una tecnología bastante reciente. Las computadoras digitales electrónicas
se construyeron por primera vez en la década de 1940. La herramienta más antigua conocida para el cómputo es el ábaco sumerio,
que los expertos creen que fue inventado en Babilonia entre 2700 y 2300 a.C. Eso es realmente
hace mucho tiempo, pero hemos llegado a entender cada vez más el mundo natural, desde Arquímedes hasta Euclid, hasta
Einstein; nuestra necesidad de más recursos computacionales ha crecido de manera explosiva. Hoy tenemos supercomputadoras, que son
básicamente muchas computadoras muy potentes conectadas en paralelo. Son una de las mejores herramientas que tiene la humanidad para
resolver problemas difíciles, pero aún hay muchos problemas que incluso estas enormes computadoras nunca podrán
resolver. Hablaremos más sobre esto después. Entonces, hemos establecido que los seres humanos han estado usando la física y la naturaleza para ayudarnos a computar
durante miles de años, y para ayudarnos en nuestra interminable búsqueda de computar cosas cada vez más grandes. Quizás ya
conoces la Ley de Moore. En realidad no es una ley como tal, sino una observación. La parte de "ley" es un poco
irónica en mi opinión. El número máximo de transistores en un circuit integrado, básicamente un chip de computadora,
se duplica aproximadamente cada 2 años. Durante las últimas 5 décadas no solo hemos observado esto, sino que hemos hecho un gran uso de
ello. Con más transistores podemos realizar más cómputos y más rápido. Esto es esencialmente lo que es responsable de
hacer que las computadoras sean cada vez más potentes y más pequeñas con el tiempo. Sin embargo, hay malas noticias: la ley de Moore se está muriendo.
Los expertos no se ponen de acuerdo sobre cuándo llegará a su fin, pero algunos dicen que ya ha ocurrido. Aunque puede que no
sepamos exactamente cuándo llegaremos a nuestro límite, sabemos que eventualmente es inevitable, porque algunas partes de los transistores
no pueden hacerse físicamente más pequeñas. No puedes hacer un transistor más pequeño que un átomo, por ejemplo. Esto
es, por supuesto, completamente imposible físicamente. Suena absurdo, pero esos son los límites con los que realmente trabajamos. Entonces, ¿qué
haremos? ¿Simplemente rendirnos y decir "así de bueno es"? No, los seres humanos nunca han hecho eso. Por suerte, la mecánica cuántica
ha entrado en la conversación. La mecánica cuántica fue descubierta en la década de 1920 y, desde entonces, el mundo
literalmente nunca ha vuelto a ser el mismo. Podríamos pasar horas hablando de los descubrimientos revolucionarios que se
hicieron, pero ese no es realmente el enfoque de este curso. En cambio, quiero dejar claro que sabemos que la mecánica cuántica
y la computación ya son compatibles entre sí. Los hallazgos y la comprensión de la naturaleza
que aprendimos de la mecánica cuántica han contribuido en parte a hacer posibles nuestras computadoras modernas. Sin la mecánica cuántica
no entenderíamos, ni probablemente hubiéramos podido inventar, el disco duro de estado sólido, por
ejemplo. La computación cuántica es simplemente el siguiente paso natural en esta evolución.
Pero la computación no existe en el vacío; la información requiere un medio.
El cómputo de información aprovecha el mundo físico y también lo afecta. Esto impone limitaciones sobre lo que es
físicamente posible, pero entender la naturaleza y las limitaciones físicas es en realidad el objetivo de la física como
disciplina. Así que, en cierto modo, la física y la computación siempre han estado entrelazadas. Ralph Landauer, un científico informático e
investigador de IBM, reconoció hace décadas que la información es física. Dicho de otra manera, la información no es una
entidad abstracta, sino que existe únicamente a través de su representación física. El principio de Landauer establece una conexión
entre la información y las leyes de la termodinámica, pero de hecho hay muchas conexiones entre la física y
la computación. La física clásica fue todo lo que pudimos explorar hasta hace poco, pero con el descubrimiento de la mecánica cuántica
ahora estamos en el umbral de poder crear una manera completamente nueva de computar. Y esto es genial, porque
las computadoras clásicas solo pueden aproximar lo que ocurre realmente en la naturaleza, y en algunos casos esa aproximación es muy
limitada. Eso se debe a que es muy, muy difícil lograr que máquinas que siguen las leyes de la física clásica
aproximen las leyes de la física cuántica. Y la naturaleza no es clásica; es cuántica. Una analogía que puede ayudarte a
entender esto es un túnel de viento. La dinámica de fluidos es notoriamente difícil de simular y predecir matemáticamente.
Incluso algo tan mundano como un auto moviéndose a través del viento. Los fabricantes de autos descubrieron que era
demasiado costoso e impracticable intentar simular esta interacción física cuando diseñaban autos. En cambio, lo que
terminaron haciendo fue crear un túnel literal que sopla viento a través de él, y simplemente meter un auto en el túnel
y ver cómo se comporta. Esto es análogo a lo que quiero decir cuando digo que las computadoras clásicas solo
aproximan pobremente la naturaleza, y a veces es demasiado costoso incluso intentar que lo hagan. En lugar de simular el viento
los investigadores simplemente lo recrean; de manera similar, las computadoras cuánticas no tienen que aproximar las leyes de la naturaleza a
nivel molecular porque siguen esas leyes de forma intrínseca; no tienen que simular nada, lo emulan, y
las mismas dificultades surgen cuando simulamos baterías o reacciones químicas, lo que nos lleva a nuestra próxima
sección: computación cuántica, ¿para qué sirve?
¿Por qué querríamos siquiera pensar en combinar la mecánica cuántica y la computación? Bueno, ya hay muchos
problemas que son demasiado difíciles, demasiado costosos computacionalmente incluso para nuestras supercomputadoras de vanguardia
quizás son problemas en los que solo los investigadores están muy enfocados, pero sus impactos podrían afectar a todas las partes del
mundo. Estos problemas en los que las computadoras clásicas se quedan atascadas son cosas en las que nosotros como sociedad dependemos cada vez más de
la tecnología y que realmente nos importan, como la eficiencia de las baterías, el modelado financiero y la
optimización, e incluso cómo construir mejores aviones. ¿Por qué recurrir a las computadoras cuánticas? Tenemos muy buenas razones
para creer que hay mucho potencial aquí y podemos abrir puertas a nuevas computaciones que actualmente están fuera del alcance incluso de las
supercomputadoras más potentes. En teoría, algunos algoritmos cuánticos ofrecen ventajas sobre los
mejores algoritmos clásicos posibles para algunas aplicaciones. Para otras aplicaciones, hay evidencia creciente de que incluso
con algo de ruido e imperfecciones, las computadoras cuánticas aún pueden usarse como herramienta para competir con la fuerza bruta clásica
básicamente es una herramienta completamente nueva y queremos descubrir aún más cosas geniales que podemos hacer con ella, pero también podemos
recurrir a la idea original de Feynman para ellas, que es usarlas para entender la física y la naturaleza en sí mismas
después de todo, ya te dije que la naturaleza es cuántica, no clásica, y este campo es increíblemente rico, fascinante e
interdisciplinario: une la física, las ciencias de la computación, el procesamiento de información y, por supuesto, los dominios específicos de las áreas de aplicación que
nos podrían interesar. Sin embargo, a diferencia de las computadoras clásicas, no todo el mundo tiene una computadora cuántica guardada en el
bolsillo trasero. Hasta hace muy poco, si querías experimentar con una computadora cuántica, tenías que construir y mantener
una tú mismo, normalmente en un triste laboratorio en el sótano de una universidad o centro de investigación, y créeme que yo lo sé. Eso ya no es
el caso: en 2016 IBM puso el primer procesador cuántico en la nube. En ese momento tenía solo cinco qubits y
tasas de error bastante altas, pero eso fue hace solo 8 años y mira lo lejos que hemos llegado. Entonces, ¿dónde estamos hoy?
Hay muchos paralelismos que se pueden trazar con los primeros días de la computadora moderna. Como mencioné, este es un reto muy
difícil y fue solo en los últimos 8 años que las computadoras cuánticas se volvieron ampliamente disponibles, excepto para
quienes trabajaban en un laboratorio o instalación de vanguardia. Pero en esos últimos ocho años hemos avanzado en todos los
frentes: los procesadores son órdenes de magnitud más grandes en número de qubits, los gates han mejorado mucho y hemos introducido métodos
para reducir o mitigar los errores intrínsecos de los sistemas cuánticos, incluso mientras avanzamos para crear computadoras cuánticas
tolerantes a fallos. Ahora tú y cualquier otra persona pueden usar uno de estos numerosos procesadores cuánticos de IBM que están
alojados en la nube, casi todos los cuales son los sistemas más nuevos, más recientes y mejores con más de 100
qubits. Pero no es solo el tamaño de los procesadores lo que importa; esta es solo una métrica que nos interesa, y
tiene sentido, ¿verdad? Si tenemos más qubits, eso es obviamente mejor, siempre que aumentar el número de qubits
no degrade el rendimiento. Sin embargo, este no siempre es el caso: necesitamos más qubits de buena calidad que no interfieran
entre sí mediante crosstalk cuando no queremos que lo hagan. La forma en que los qubits están conectados entre sí también es algo importante a tener en cuenta. En los
circuits superconductores es todo un reto determinar cómo conectar físicamente mejor los qubits. Otra métrica enormemente importante
es la fidelidad de los gates de dos qubits. Los gates que operan en qubits individuales no son tan propensos a errores; los gates de dos qubits son la zona de
mayor preocupación y suelen ser una de las métricas de referencia que buscamos para ver cómo mejora el rendimiento a lo largo del
tiempo. Los gates de dos qubits son cruciales de implementar correctamente porque son los responsables de crear entrelazamiento entre los qubits,
que es uno de los fenómenos físicos que otorga a las computadoras cuánticas su poder. Por último, buscamos velocidad y eficiencia:
necesitamos asegurarnos de que el tiempo que se tarda en ejecutar un programa en el chip cuántico sea lo más rápido y eficiente
posible. Nos referimos a estas tres métricas en conjunto como escala, calidad y
velocidad; todas son vitales para mejorar el rendimiento. Ahora quiero mostrarte algunos gráficos rápidos para respaldar lo que he estado
diciendo sobre cómo la tecnología en sí realmente está evolucionando bastante rápido. El recuento de qubits en sí mismo es el más fácil de
entender, creo, e IBM ha publicado una hoja de ruta de dónde esperamos estar en los próximos años en términos de recuento de qubits
y tamaño del procesador. Para 2024, cuando grabamos este video, estamos justo en camino con nuestros procesadores Heron y Condor. A continuación,
calidad: este gráfico muestra la tasa de error mediana de los gates de entrelazamiento para los procesadores cuánticos de IBM a lo largo del tiempo. Ten en
cuenta que esta es una escala logarítmica, así que aunque el progreso parece vagamente lineal, en realidad es mucho más rápido de lo que parece.
Por último, tenemos la velocidad. Este gráfico muestra el progreso de una métrica que llamamos CLOPS, que corresponde a circuit layer
operations per second. De manera crucial, CLOPS encapsula tanto el tiempo que tarda en ejecutar circuits como el cómputo clásico real y
en tiempo cercano necesario. Básicamente, CLOPS es una medida de qué tan rápido nuestros procesadores pueden ejecutar circuits específicos en
serie, actuando como una medida de la velocidad holística del sistema e incorporando la computación cuántica y clásica.
Ahora mismo, en el momento de la grabación, IBM es el único proveedor cuántico en la nube que ofrece acceso a máquinas de más de 100
qubits. Como mencioné hace unos minutos, 100 qubits o alrededor de ahí es donde la simulación clásica
comienza a fallar por completo, por lo que los trabajos a gran escala que se ejecutan en estas máquinas a menudo no tienen equivalente clásico; simplemente no es
posible. Hay algunos matices y trucos que puedes usar para simular algunas partes de un circuit y luego otras
partes por separado, pero en general sabemos que alrededor de este número es donde las computadoras cuánticas pueden empezar a hacer cosas que las computadoras clásicas simplemente no pueden. Así que
IBM decidió que dar acceso a estos dispositivos más grandes era muy importante para la comunidad en general, porque cualquier cosa
que se haga en dispositivos más pequeños es simulable clásicamente y, por lo tanto, no puede llevar a la Ventaja Cuántica. Los dispositivos de 100 qubits
que tenemos ahora todavía son imperfectos y todavía tienen ruido, por lo que necesitamos ser inteligentes sobre cómo ejecutamos trabajos y
circuits en ellos. Escribir nuestro circuit ingenuamente y presionar shift enter probablemente no va a llevar a nada
espectacular, pero de nuevo hay trucos y mejores prácticas que podemos implementar para exprimir incluso
más rendimiento de estos dispositivos, lo que esperamos lleve a la Ventaja Cuántica más pronto, incluso mientras continuamos
trabajando en construir nuestras máquinas tolerantes a fallos también. Este gráfico muestra el costo de simulación
o el tiempo que tarda en resolver un problema en computadoras clásicas y computadoras cuánticas equipadas con mitigación de
errores y corrección de errores. La línea de computación clásica escala exponencialmente a medida que crece la complejidad del circuit:
para circuits simples aquí abajo no importa, pero obviamente es malo a medida que crece la complejidad porque esto hace que
el costo de simulación sea muy costoso muy rápido. La mitigación de errores escala mejor, así que cuando crece la complejidad del
circuit es ahí donde queremos estar. Actualmente estamos aquí con los métodos clásicos y los métodos cuánticos más o menos a la
par para algunas aplicaciones, y la corrección de errores podría ser la más preferible y escala muy
bien; simplemente aún no hemos llegado ahí. Mientras tanto, seguiremos enfocándonos en la mitigación de errores y en llegar a esta
área de utilidad cuántica lo antes posible. Y haciendo uso de varios esquemas de mitigación de errores, que
aprenderemos en esta serie, buscamos encontrar áreas de aplicación que puedan hacer uso de la utilidad cuántica muy pronto. Y eso es
realmente el corazón de este curso: tenemos estas máquinas y creemos que son capaces de hacer investigaciones realmente interesantes.
¿Cómo las usamos? En esta última sección del episodio, hablemos brevemente sobre las áreas de aplicación para
la computación cuántica práctica. Hay tres ramas principales que creemos que nos entusiasman más explorar y encontrar caminos para la utilidad
cuántica. La primera es simular la naturaleza: esto tiene que ver con simular interacciones moleculares o atómicas, y esto es
realmente importante para áreas de ciencia de materiales y química. Por las razones que discutimos antes, creemos que las computadoras cuánticas
serán mucho mejores en esto que sus contrapartes de computadoras clásicas. A continuación está la búsqueda y la
optimización. El algoritmo principal de interés aquí se llama QAOA, un algoritmo híbrido cuántico-clásico. QAOA usa una
computadora clásica para entrenar y encontrar parámetros óptimos para un circuit cuántico, y esperamos poder hacer esto
mucho más eficientemente de lo que podría cualquier computadora por sí sola. Por último, tenemos matemáticas y procesamiento de datos con estructura: las computadoras cuánticas
son muy buenas para encontrar estructura en datos desordenados donde tú, yo o una computadora típica quizás no
veamos nada. El aprendizaje automático cuántico es prometedor en esta área y aspiramos a usarlo para tareas como la extracción de
características y el reconocimiento de patrones. Realmente es un momento muy emocionante para quienes trabajamos en el
campo de la computación cuántica. Por primera vez en la historia podemos comenzar a explorar una región de la computación que va más allá de la
computación clásica. Quienes estén viendo esto podrían jugar un papel similar al de los primeros pioneros de la
computación, y ellos no tenían ninguna concepción de lo que vendría después. T. J. Watson de IBM incluso llegó a decir famosamente que creía que había
mercado para solo dos o tres computadoras en total, y vaya si se equivocó. Nosotros
somos todos esos primeros pioneros de la computación, pero en este nuevo campo de la computación cuántica. Y lo cuántico suele
contrastarse con la computación clásica como algo claramente diferente de ella y a menudo en competencia con ella, pero mi
objetivo con esta conferencia introductoria era convencerte de que desde una vista panorámica podemos ver la computación
cuántica simplemente como el próximo capítulo de una larga historia de la computación. Es parte de nuestra naturaleza como humanos buscar nuevas formas de
computar, de aprovechar el poder del mundo natural y de descubrir qué hacer con él, y lo hemos estado haciendo durante
siglos. La computación cuántica nos ofrece una nueva herramienta en esta empresa, y depende de nosotros descubrir cómo aprovechar
el poder que nos ofrece. En la próxima lección de la serie hablaremos un poco más sobre los sistemas de 100 qubits
y daremos una descripción general de Qiskit, nuestro SDK de software cuántico, y cómo interactuar mejor con estas máquinas ahora mismo. Gracias por
ver el video y nos vemos la próxima vez.